flying submarines are a common idea both
in science fiction and in real life but
this robotic insects may be the smallest
one out there
researchers have built a small robot
that can move as well underwater as it
can in the air the small machine was
adapted from an earlier design that
could only fly but in order to make it
swim they had to go back to the drawing
board first it needed help staying
oriented while underwater the bot only
weighs 175 milligrams about the same as
a raindrop so to keep it from losing
control they added underwater
stabilizers and slowed down the wing
beats when flying the robots wings flap
about 250 times a second to keep the
robot from spinning around wildly in the
water they slowed it down to around 9
beats per second while submerged but the
robot needs a way to get out of the
water once it's underneath to solve this
problem the researcher is turned to
electrolysis electrolysis is a chemical
reaction jump-started by an electric
current in water electrolysis breaks up
the h2o molecules into hydrogen and
oxygen
the researchers attached an electrolysis
device to the robot as well as an
electric spark when the apparatus is
activated the robot creates a buildup of
gas in a chamber beneath itself and when
the sparkler ignites the reaction
Rockets the bot to a height of 30
centimeters even though it can't fly
when wet the robot can still glide
safely back to land and when it's dry
take to the skies once again while you
won't see the spot flying or swimming in
your neighborhood soon the researchers
are confident that in the future this
robotic insects could be used for help
and disaster cleanup or environmental
surveys
[Music]
[Music]